we didn't really miss a day
in spite of the pandemic um we went
from a friday in the room together to a
monday
on zoom uh and so we are work we're all
working and by the way um
vince gil vince hadn't been in the room
for the last few seasons and he's come
back
uh and he is he is fully he is he is
he's on fire
in a row and as there's so many great
big ideas that we have in so many
wonderful um
scenes and we're we're right now we're
on
uh we're i think we're pretty close to
finishing episode four
and we have a um we have an idea
for everything that you asked about we
have an idea
of where we think this is going where
what ends this all this uh we have an
idea about
characters who might or might not return
like like well jesse we have thoughts
uh but you know we're as you know we
said earlier in the conversation
uh you don't want to commit to anything
too much because things change and if um
if the story veers zigzag or zags in a
way that makes it impossible for us to
have
even beloved characters uh back we won't
have them back because our our goal is
to
have us have a story that makes sense on
its own
and is not dependent on um
on those references or or that but
having said that
um i got to be in albuquerque actually
i i made a point of flying to
albuquerque with my family
for one day of the el camino shoot and
there was you know
brian flew in secretly
uh and there was aaron and they were in
that i'm sure you seen alchemy in that
great scene of the diner
uh that vince rhoden directed and we
spent a day watching these two guys and
then we had dinner together
and it was it was such a special thing
to see those two guys as those
characters again
they are they are unique they're bigger
than life
uh but and and it was such a terrific
scene i like to think that we don't
have as much of an obligation to have
walt and jesse back on better call saul
because
they're such a great appearance on uh in
el camino
but having said that i would love boy i
would love to have them back i'd love to
have brian direct an episode
yeah i got to i got to write an episode
that brian directed and i was there on
set with him every day
and it was it was a wonderful experience
he is he is a magnificent director he's
one of the few
directors who is has a facility for
comedy
and for the lightest comedy and the
darkest drama and can flip back and
forth he's
he's remarkable he's a and he's a great
guy love i'd love to work with both of
them and aaron paul is uh
possibly the happiest human being i've
ever met and and he makes everybody
around him happy so yeah i would love to
have them back
i think uh fans would love to see them
back um
i know you have to go one last question
for you i was kind of curious
i know the final season is more episodes
than
you guys usually have i was kind of
curious what the decision was behind
that i'm not complaining
love to see well you know we
it's really a it's a thumbnail and i we
talked about it a lot and
one of the concerns i had was i kept
saying you know i barely survive
physically making it through 10 episodes
how are we going to do 13
uh and then you know tom schnauz said to
me you know
you'll know it's the last 13 so you know
you'll see that
you'll see you'll you'll see the barn
door in the dis the barn in the distance
you'll be like
the horse that gallops down the last bit
uh and so i took that i took that and
but you know we also have a lot to do
um there's a lot we have a lot of story
and so
it's a little bit of a it's a little bit
of a guess
to be honest with you uh you know is
what's the right number
you know is it you know is it is it nine
is it 16 is it you know you kind of
you're kind of is it 10
10 doesn't seem like enough i don't
think we're physically capable of making
15 um and it would probably take so long
that everyone would be bored with
waiting for us
uh so i think you know that was we kind
of settled on 13
and uh i have to say here we are
breaking episode four
i think it's the right number and i'm
really hoping
uh i'm really hoping that we stick the
landing i i people are really tough
on serious enders now yeah that's what's
the thing it's making me all nervous
it's making me a little nervous because
people are very uh
they're it makes me realize watching all
the shows that
have a series ending and then getting a
little look at the different opinions
about it it's very tough
to take you know in our case it'll be 63
hours roughly
of story and then run it to a satisfying
conclusion
uh and then plus we have the breaking
bad of it
so i yeah i know your my hair is gonna
fall out in the next five seconds
talking about it we'll do our best
i i'm excited